this
youtube video claiming assad is the
enemy of allah
is one of the things that inspired a man
working in an old people's home in
holland
to go and fight jihad in syria
two years on and gilmars is still in
syria with bullets
strapped to his chest the former dutch
soldier is training others to fight
many of them british i spoke to him via
skype
among the age group that come in what
are the youngest people you're seeing
from
say from the uk i think it's 16 17
17. so teenagers teenagers
people as young as 16 have come
that kind of thing it's funny i mean the
british government itself
is funding and training
beating jordan or wherever here in syria
uh the free syrian army so basically
the british government is helping and
i'm helping in my way
and what is your goal
basically the main goal is is getting
rid of this regime
bringing in place an islamic
government that's built upon islamic
principles
security services in the uk estimate
four to five hundred british jihadists
are fighting in syria but why
this british-born londoner converted to
islam six years ago and would like to go
again he's inspired by videos this one
shows people forced
to pray to assad an insult to his
beliefs
they worship bashar al-assad over god
what personally would drive you
to want to go and fight me personally
just
to be able to aid others but at the same
time the main purpose is because it
pleases god
it's the best death of you today out
there on the battlefield
it will be the best death but at the
same time even if i did die
i've done something good for people and
that would be surely written down as a
good deed
solomon says family circumstances mean
he can't go
right now but is in a small minority of
muslims who see it as a duty
the overwhelming majority of muslims
will reject going out to fight isis and
rightly so
they shouldn't go it's not islamic it's
not
what the prophet peace be upon him talks
about but the problem is
a small number will go and they're the
people that we need to worry about
yesterday muhammad ahmed and yusuf sawah
from birmingham pleaded guilty to
terrorism offences
after spending eight months in syria
last year and contacting islamist
extremists
what you need is a person that
wants to go and he'll find his way
but it's not like booking a beach
holiday or something like that i mean
you say it's easy it is it is people
book holidays
but they end up in syria
we've seen the videos of fresh-faced
british muslims in syria calling for
others to join them
both the men we spoke to yilmaz and
suleiman insist the majority of fighters
pose no threat to their home country
but accept that a handful might there's
always a chance of a loose scanner
doing something stupid or doing
something crazy
and yilmaz knows he can't go back i'm
stuck here
but i want to be sick this is all i ever
wanted
this is all i ever wanted jason farrell
sky news